hi everyone it's jerry i am going to
play
against
magnus
on the play magnus app
a bit of a fun video
see
how many different levels or ages of
magnus i can defeat
and what do we need to know here
h5 magnus the story
he was excited about playing
noches really wasn't interested yet
spent his time memorizing the population
flagging capitals of the countries of
the world
okay i did do a test run
with this
and the early
magnus's
have a tendency to throw away a lot of a
lot of material
so i'm not expecting
too much resistance in the early going
here
under developing what's that rook a7
move doing
okay we're just going to take free
material
that's really bad wow might as well go
into pac-man mode here maybe take a
night get a queen
i feel like there might be even better
though
whatever we'll take
we'll take the night
holland to check
where's the mate
oh that knight is defended by my by my
queen so we got two nights
not quite mate
take a bishop
threatening me in a couple i think
or now since that move we got me one
okay some confetti
for the first one
all right i'm expecting just about uh
you know each of these games to maybe
take
two or three minutes in the early going
so let's see what's in store for us with
magnus five and a half it goes up to age
30 on this app
he is
31 but uh the app isn't fully updated i
guess
age five and a half magnus he was a fan
of soccer playing a lot of soccer four
to five hours each day okay
team black in this one still no
development for magnus
try to be principled oh
magnus at five and a half
got fooled
a quick mate
okay we will get resistance i can assure
you of that
uh but not magnus five and a half
so much for two or three minutes
what was that 30 seconds okay
magnus the pirate
this time around he was a fan of the
pirate captain sabretooth
okay he liked dressing up
as a pirate as a six-year-old
all right that's cute
let's go
let's try not to get defeated by
the pirate
alright i like
putting a pawn in black's house with
tempo
no reaction by magnus just yet i don't
even want to take another pawn there
i'm just going to keep bringing the
pieces out
more free stuff
okay
so i really don't have any uh idea of
the rating level it's very very tough to
gauge
the uh playing strength in the early
going it
all feels super
low level
but there will be a point
where it becomes super difficult
and i think that happens pretty fast
so i don't know let's go here
give the knight up let me try and mate
really quick
threatening mate in a couple
i think i was threatening mate in a
couple
you gonna take that night
i guess so at least i have the c file
opened
all right controlling the c file now i
think there is a maintenance ii
let's defend it again
is running a mate in one
that's defended
are we there yet
oh you know what i didn't realize i have
bishop to a5
that would have been good too
and a block
this was clearly not the most efficient
approach here but in the end we get the
w okay
this will end though
where will it end okay magnus not quite
seven magnus six and a half is up next
and as a six and a half year old what
was he doing
number crunching
sports books okay let's go
team black
that's a little better of a start there
b3
i don't know about a3 though i can't
draw any lines
so
i'll have to just
hopefully know the coordinates well
enough
get out of there
i also say that's a flight square
okay my knights are on pretty squares
i like that
might as well chop away
okay you should have recaptured
take another pawn
still no recapture
all right i'm going to save that guy now
that light square bishop is having a
tough day at the office
i'll say uh you go ahead and take me an
e4
okay rook to what is soon to be an open
file
all right i have a discover check
do i have
better
how about this we go here and then plant
the rook
right in there and that intersection
squirrel take towards the center
and i'm on the queen
could take the queen so they're
better where's the mate i feel like
there should be a mate
we'll give a check here
going back home
all right i'll take the queen
and i
guess take the bishop
all right what are you up to
i don't even want the knight mate and
two threat
all right we get a mate in three one
two
and then mate on c2
okay that one's in the books
more confetti
yeah let's go
up next
magnus
seven
all right so this is where his interest
in chess peaked
watching his dad
older sister
uh yeah watching his dad an older sister
okay
okay uh how about e4
okay the
alkynes defense well at least you're
reacting to the threat
there we go f6
not good super weakening to the king
side
knight is supported
feels it feels like it's really close to
maybe another fool's mate not quite
though there is g6 if i play queen h5
there i'm not too
too afraid of that knight on b4
i'll swipe this pawn
and maybe set up a cool
a cool trick let me save the bishop
bishop g5 is another good move
denied
all right let's go knight c3
now the queen is there
a half open file
getting the pieces out
bishop and queen
still in the driver's seat here though
no problems let's flush this knight away
if knight d5 i could have captured
because there's this pin on the e file
okay that's just free stuff
and probably smash through here now
there we go
i was up some material don't be afraid
to give some back where's this bishop
along
uh i want to go to f4
yeah how about this put the knight in
the center i'm threatening the knight on
c6 now
okay i could take here it is check my
rook is defended as well
okay queen there
i am up a piece now
still feels clumsy with this bishop okay
how about g3 bishop f4
i'll claim i have that flight square
okay i guess we'll go for the queen
exchange it may take a little longer
to dust off mr
carlson here seven-year-old carlson
he's running for the hills now
can we get him eight
in a few can we set it up and maintain
two seems to be really good at ducking
mate and one threats
okay
i don't know king towards the center
rook d6 is not quite made
let's start with this threatening main
two rook d5
yeah there we go denied
how about this maybe we get a passport
we'll go like this eventually the rook
has to give itself up
okay any moment where are we at it's
gonna be i don't know mate in
less than 10
thinking
score another touchdown here
go with that
one
it's no stalemate so
got plenty of pawns it should be mate
next there we go all right in the books
game
i should say magnus ace h7
okay
uh is this gonna be the tricky level
seven and a half
um what was he into
football
still
spent a full year enjoying the 12-month
football season
while living in waterloo
pretending to be harry potter okay
definitely
cannot lose to harry potter here
let's go with the sicilian
okay that is a pawn that i feel like i
could try and track down might as well
start with a developing move put some
pressure on it it isn't defended
so i could take it right away okay more
free stuff
um
i could land a check
i'll go here it's a little awkward
obstructing my center pawn
but hey
we just want some more material
and still no development no resistance
just yet
i think it might be magnus eight
save the night i guess
okay i probably could have just
withdrawn the knight it's a little
clumsy here i guess we'll save the
b-pawn
doing some kind of bishop shuffle i
don't know what that's about
and the queen
likes to move the same piece more than
once
all right let's make sure this file
stays opened i don't want to take with
the pawn there
might as well pin the knight
maybe we open up another file let's
start with this check
got another check
is it almost mate
is it almost mate
i'll give this check
and are we there yet
he's on the edge
i'll go with the queen
i have to have to block with the pawnee
can i set up something cool i was just
thinking some pawn move up and then
knight to b5
pawn takes pawn discover checkmate
not quite
maybe maybe i could try for that
that'd be cool
trying to be a little artistic here
setting it up we'll take with the knight
on keep the rook in the corner
oh well so much for the uh
oh maybe i could still set it up
i could give up my queen
bishop takes queen of threatening
maintenance ii
oh
once more giving up giving a square up
to the king the knight is poison
he's running for the hills
okay i guess we go like this
i'm not really up a whole lot of
material
oh but it'll it'll do the trick
all right i have a discovery with the
bishop
see
trying to be fancy got me nowhere
i guess we'll go with this
grab a pony
and maybe give another check
oh i might have just blundered there i
could have got back what if queen takes
knight in that position
i i couldn't take back because my rook
was hanging
oh man
okay
uh
yeah so much for a quick win wasn't i up
a boatload of material just a couple
seconds ago
i think i might have had something even
if uh
uh you know there was that
i think i could have maybe defended
if it went for that back rank mate thing
i played too fast
too fancy
too fast and too fancy
and now it's taking forever
okay
i just want to see magnus
magnus eight watch out for a sneaky pawn
move okay no stalemates
oh man how many mates did i miss
nobody knows
okay we gotta get a touchdown here
you got one square that's good enough
uh how about we keep the king sealed in
here
he got just one square here
flirting with danger
check
check
and finally me okay this took way too
long
my heart skipped a beat on that one
harry potter
could have shocked me there
okay
let's go
up next
eight
year old magnus
this is where he beat his sister
as an eight-year-old
and
some books
he was
into
a couple books mentioned here find the
plan
and complete
or the complete dragon okay
the dragon eh
okay
okay well that is a good start magnus
eight is this where there's a
significant change in the play style
i already get that impression
d5 is good knight f6 is good
c6 is good
i better slow it down a little bit
let's start with this
i just want to be in a spot to recapture
upon i guess we'll go to f4
i don't care too much about double duh
double duh double def pawns
oh
i'll go here bishop d3 was worth
considering as well
all right it feels like that queen is
asking for some trouble namely knight e5
um
but i really don't
i'm i could probably do that next move
there's no stopping that knight advance
okay so this is where
black is really starting to go astray i
would say queen d7 is where it began
okay now now he's
magnus's gun
crazy town
what's going on here i could take the
bishop or take the queen hit him with an
in-betweener on f6
i have a nice pick i'll go with the
variation where the queen is still on
maybe i could manage to uh
win the game with the queens the
original
queen aboard
okay threatening something maybe
pawn advance with discovery
um
what do we want to do oh i could go here
initially i was thinking that was a free
bishop but it is defended by my knight
i do have c7 discovered check
um
yeah i guess we'll do that
bishop b5 follow-up pin
yeah i guess so
that one
we'll take this pawn
uh uh you're ready to develop
yeah the king is gonna find safety oh
well
um
i was ready to go queen b8 the knight
isn't uh
isn't able to take
how do i want to play this
i guess we'll go here
still after some material
see ya i'm just noticing now he's uh
he just said something there see uh
what was he doing trash talking
i wasn't paying any attention to those
words that were coming up i'll have to
take note
was he saying you got no game
he might have been saying that
all right
how about
this one
and then knight b
knight b6
okay i'll get more material
all right so i've lost count
how much material am i up
let's start with this offer a queen
exchange also pin the knight i was
setting up bishop h6
taking advantage of the pin
and here we are again
i ha i can't mate the only mate i had
with the queen on
oh no
i had that fool's mate
but uh
yeah it seems like he's
really good with ducking
the one or two
move mates
all right how can we be
efficient here
all right let's let's cut you off from
trying to maybe hide behind your uh
your pawns
you know
try and make you in the center of the
board
boom
and then rook on the e file there we go
okay another trophy
more confetti
and coming up more resistance
because this time
ah this time it is magnus eight no not
eight and a half and nine year old
magnus who
at the time was interested in
ski jumping
okay
let's go
all right e4
how about
let's go
let's go with the kerocon
okay and d5
let's get my bishop out and about
okay that um h was that a mouse slip
h3 because h4 is a move trying to hunt
my light square bishop
all right let's go with c5
so
we need
one day some activity for our brooks and
the c file is gonna be it
all right
um
i'll go with brooke here
and
let me ask that guy an immediate
question i don't like being in pins so
all right
i guess i'll initiate the exchange
and
okay let's go with this one
if pawn takes i have knight g6
or do i
okay hopefully i'm able to hunt down
that e5 pawn there is queen e3
all right
so that c pawn is gonna be hung onto i
get this guy here
all right
do i need to slow down
i might i might be going a little too
fast here with magnus nine
i feel like there should have been a
much smoother way i i'm not really a big
fan of this particular structure
i don't like uh
that my rook and bishop are
biting at that c5 pawn
the c5b b4 construction is
really interfering with the quality of
my pieces but
it should be all right let's get on with
development i could play b6 to break
that point down
but let's begin with some security
and maybe now i go ahead and challenge
that pawn
try and get him out of my house before
he hurts me
okay not doing anything about that
um i don't really care if
um yeah i'll go ahead and capture i was
gonna say i don't care if
my knight is captured and i have double
g pawns i have to be a little bit
careful of g7 oh
so sneaky
threatening mate on g7
so there's there's definitely a
a difference in playing strength
and with magnus age nine
no doubt
so bishop right there
not so great
i'm gonna go here
with the idea to get rid of my isolated
pawn with a5
i don't want to take too soon on b5
because i would simply help out the rook
in the corn the rook on a1
so this is a this is an instance where
it i think black does well to maintain
the tension
uh
let's
let's simply go with this one and then
now i'm ready for a5 and i don't have
any worries of b5
i could take it straight away so now i
could chop
chop away but before i initiate these
captures i'm going to make one prep move
maybe even another one
let's go right here once more
maintaining the tension
and i think at this stage now i'm ready
to go ahead and chop away
does the order really matter a whole lot
i'll begin with this one just so there's
maybe not some variation where white
acquires an outside past a pawn
i think it would still be good for me if
that
if that did happen but all right
definitely
uh
a difference in the play here
let's get to the second rank
i'm not sure what i would do
there's if there's a
is there a take back if i make some
mouse slip
some screen slip
alright we got some wild pigs
on the second
i'm up now a third
pawn let's stop that guy from going any
further
do you have that flight square
and let's work on my king improvement
just a little bit
and let's move these
connected passers
oh
fancy
i'm just going to constantly harass my
rook
is that what you're planning
okay if i mean if i try to
threatening a mate in a few i think
let's let's keep going with this guy
eventually i'll control a ton of
a ton of squares if rook to e1 i have a
mate in two
all right are we there yet let's take
this one rook takes pawn i have the mate
i don't care about taking another one
yeah maybe i do all right i'm up five
pawns now
i think we're close
to mate now
where's the mate
i can't find the mate
all right maybe we go for a five pawn
attack
let me
let me safeguard my king
there we go
nice little shield here okay now we got
a main two there's maybe something a
little quicker
somewhere there
with the wild pigs on the second
hungry pieces they like to eat ponds
okay i think this is where i need to
tone it down
not get too excited don't play too fast
because this is where
he means business i'm pretty sure
uh
yeah magnus age 10
magnus age 10 what was he up to
this is where he was starting to play in
junior and adult tournaments
first attempt at international master
qualifying group he finished with five
draws and five losses
if you're 10 years old or younger you
can beat me at age 10.
wait what does he say if you are 10
years old or younger and you can beat me
at 10 you should definitely continue
playing your chess ah see
there it is this is where
he means business i'm pretty sure
all right so
let's start with
d4
i still have yet to uh
take note
of those messages that keep linking
where his name is
i guess i'll see it when i'm editing the
video
okay
so what do we have here we have a queens
indian
how do i want to approach this maybe
maybe
should i lean on uh
one of the model games
i have in mind when alpha zero is
playing as white
or yeah
alpha zero is a big fan of going with a
king side fianchetto in reply to the
queen's indian
is that an approach i want to take
or should i be looking for something
else i guess we'll
i guess we'll go with g3 yeah okay so
queen c2
and the bishop returns
so this often involves gambit play
okay let's begin with this one
and the gambit is usually this d5 move
i'm not sure in this exact position
though
yeah i'm not sure here
um one of the benefits of d5 in this
position
you you give up the pawn but you have
access to that uh f5 square
for the queen
or
as alpha zero played in one of the games
and also the knight that would be the
more menacing piece knight h
knight uh
h4 into f5
okay well
how do i want to approach this here
should i play d5
i don't know if i want to allow the pawn
to take me and i don't think i don't
think i want to recapture with my knight
and allow the bishop to be exchanged
like if i castle pawn takes knight takes
bishop takes bishop king takes bishop
so
maybe i
maybe i take on c5
yeah i really don't want to
try some gambit against
young magnus here 10 year old magnus is
is scaring me
okay let's castle
uh that move
what is the story
decentralization
and for what reason
okay the the coordination on this uh f2
square
i'm not too afraid of
because it's
you know generally it's not a good idea
if the knight and bishop are exchanged
for rook and pawn
the minor pieces tend to be more
valuable
so i'm going to
ignore it
and develop
okay we have some underdeveloping here
so with that last move there's less
pressure on f2
and
what else
i could play rook d1 that's springing to
mind or b3 bishop b2 i think i want my
bishop on the main diagonal
or i could uh i think
let me begin with this
rook to d1 move it
it feels healthy
it's
it's one of those i think
i i think i could say it's a guaranteed
a guaranteed productive move
now let's go with this
b3
eventually a rook will be on the c file
so it's worthwhile to have that c pawn
supported
also oh
if that rook is going to be on c8 my
queen probably doesn't want to hang
around on c2
much longer now that move right there
hmm
i'm not sure the point
is there's some variation where the e
where that move is justified
how does the e file somehow open up it
would it would
come about after
d5 by black but i do have enough support
for that
um
do i want to play e4 i'm not so sure i
want to play e4 let's begin with getting
this here in anticipation of a d5 break
the c file opening up
okay now there is a serious threat
on f2
my initial thought was to play e3 but
maybe there's
two pawns in a rook
is what black can go for e3 knight takes
pawn pawn takes
knight bishop takes e3 check king h1 and
then bishop takes rook
i don't really want to allow that
so i was just thinking i would play
knight e4 but i believe
uh if i play knight e4 hits the bishop
and defends f2
but there's then a move knight
b4
hitting my queen
and then next up there's bishop takes
knight and then f2 is
in trouble so
mm-hmm time to
think here
i may have to play e3
and i think black will go ahead for the
two pawns and the rook for the two
miners and
i'm not sure how that one's gonna play
out
i might be in some trouble here i could
go into a complete prevent with rook f1
already thinking back like maybe i
should have flicked in h3
before rook c1 oh well here we are
if i had a3 and already i think 94 would
be
absolute best hitting the bishop and
also ready to dive into the d6 square
which is the weakest point in black's
position currently
so
i don't think there's any three pieces
for the queen variation knight e4 knight
b4
knight takes bishop
knight takes queen knight takes bishop
the queen goes to c7 attacks my knight i
take the knight on c2 they take my
knight on b7
yeah i'm not seeing any
any great detours from that variation
um
do i go chicken mode
rook f1 is chicken mode
i may do that
or do we try and imbalance all right
let's let's try and imbalance go for it
oh you're not chopping away on e3
who's the chicken
who is the chicken now
okay how about this let's get the queen
over here so
start to hug these uh e3 and f2 squares
they're a bit sensitive okay now
just a little bit ago wasn't i saying
that d6 square was
kind of sensitive
kind of sensitive
all right uh let's go with 94 now
do should i flush the knight away with
h3
no knight f6 then i can't go to e4
i'll just say that that knight on g4 is
still kind of silly bishop a3 no bishop
a3
oh so i get the dark square bishop
i'm liking that
maybe now with this imbalance
pretty sure i should be swiping this
bishop now that there's a clear
imbalance of bishop for knight
namely unopposed dark square bishop i'm
pointing right at the heart
that uh
that g7 square
how can i take full advantage
how can i make make use of my dark skirt
bishop
well this knight i need
the black knight on a5 is unprotected so
i have queen d2
and then queen d6
and maybe i then try to simply play
against
the d7 pawn try and keep that guy
backward
i think i'm leaning towards that
yeah let's go for it
hitting the knight i'm expecting knight
c6
and
i guess
yeah i guess we'll go to d6
oh
you're simply looking to create a target
on my king side
i see
okay
well
okay i think i think right about now i
want to say
go away
and now
maybe improve my night
i think it's time to improve this guy
i'm gonna eventually have okay i'm gonna
eventually have to deal with uh
there's gonna be some sensitive point on
my queen side after a4 there's not
really a whole lot i could do to stop
that
all right
take with take the bishop and the knight
in this position
i have to play one of the two
bishop takes bishop rook b8
and then
i move my bishop and then there's a4
no what am i talking about bishop takes
bishop rook b8 if when i move my light
square bishop that knight on e5 probably
has to move
and is there a great move for it
i think i should be capturing the bishop
or the they're the full bishop pair
i'm gonna go for that
here we go and now save the bishop i
don't wanna yeah it should be keeping
the bishop so where should this guy go
um initially i'm thinking keeping on the
main diagonal but also
bishop a6 into b5
would do i think a decent job of
shielding the rook from any pressure on
my b pawn
at the same time though
i think i want to stop the knight from
getting to
the c6 square i want to be able to
chop the knight
so let's bring him home
let's go to g2
all right so i could double the pawns i
i like that if i give up
uh in this in this environment
i'm considering my better bishop to be
the dark square bishop because of the
the uh the fixed pawns on the c file
so oh i i could win a pawn let's say
take the knight pawn takes and then rook
takes c
but then i have to cope with some super
active rook
i could also maybe look to take both
knights out start with the one on f6
um
i think i
let me let me just see i think i could
liquidate this down to a technical
position i could swipe both knights and
a brook
and i believe win a pawn
in the rook ending so i think i'm gonna
begin
i'm gonna say let's give up the dark
square bishop
and then the light square bishop
and then
double on the d file
um maybe the rook exchange is ducked
hmm
or maybe i
maybe i take the
knight on f6 and then double rook
straight away
and then i'm threatening to take the
knight and i'm up a piece
okay i think i want to i think i'm going
to start with this one spending too much
time here
and now
chop the knight
or double rooks
my rook was already on c2 i'd be swiping
that knight in a heartbeat and then
taking on c6
because my base points would be covered
f2 and a2
i negate any rook d2 by black
all right so
if i play if i double rooks maybe knight
b4 is played
but then i could play rook d2
if i double rooks in knight to e5 i have
f4 the knight has to go to an awkward
square
i think i'm gonna go with doubling rooks
that one
but now
okay let's go here some defense
and that one so now i could win the pawn
and i should
yeah i should win the pawn
okay i'm up a pawn now
and
i'd really like to get rid of that
knight
i could play a3
or rook a7
wait doesn't rook a i have everything i
wanna with the rook on d2 as i was
pointing out rook on c2 or d2 in this
case i'm guarding my base points so
maybe i should feel a bit more free to
be more active with that rook that's on
the seventh
try and track down another pawn
i'm gonna go with this one
okay seven
in that move
so i could scare the knight away
i could also look to
huh
what could i look to do
i could try to pinpoint f7
bishop f3
to h5
huh
i'm gonna go for that
how is how is that stopped black is in a
pickle here
yeah let's go with this one
i could support the bishop with g4 i
don't think i i could take the pawn
straight away
do i want to do that
i don't want to take with my rook
because i'm exchanging uh my one of my
most active pieces for uh
really dead rook that's on f8
so maybe take with the bishop
and be prepared to fall back with my
bishop to h5 after a g4 move
i feel like i should be
is there any problem
if i go ahead and uh take this with the
bishop
not seeing the problem
okay rook there
okay if i double rooks
there's gonna be knight b8
he's a slippery guy
all right he's get he's exchanging my
rook
with rook c rook c7 coming up
no not playing that
okay oh well now now i have an avenue i
have a pivot square on d5
but if i play bishop d5 right now
then
one of the rooks goes to the d file i
don't like that
how can i do this how about rook to
where hmm
i feel like there should be mate soon
black is all tied up
all right let me let me save this bishop
that way i could hang on to this rook
i want to keep some pressure
okay i could take on a5
might as well
now let's take another pawn
oh
that is a little irritating
if i'm being honest
alright that night
black has carved out a square there for
the night
all right let's not fear
let's not fear anything
maybe i should have played f4 sooner
okay i could play f3 right now undermine
the the knight support on d3
feel why does it feel like my bishop is
so out of play
because it is
it is out of play
huh he is kind of stuck
so f3 pawn takes king f2 what if black
starts to double on the e file
eventually i'll have to babysit my pawn
on e3
uh
all right now now i kind of want to
exchange a rook
let's go to the corner
all right
and
maybe i maybe i track down the e pawn
allow my a pawn to get captured back
maybe maybe i should be improving my
king first though
get my king on g3
out of any checks
all right that night's so tricky
oh man
okay what about now
rookie eight
there any fancy night moves
okay let's get rid of this pawn that's
in my house
yeah
tricky nights
let's grab this one
knight b4 no knight before you're on a2
okay
i'm gonna track a pawn or two down
aren't you
i feel like i want to get my bishop out
of here
let's go here
so
so nervous about that that night
crazy guy
all right bishop a4
at some point
let's start with this
i want to control the dark squares
i guess we'll exchange rooks
yeah
i feel like i could play a little faster
knight c3 coming up get insert the check
let's go with the check first
i should watch my rook doesn't have
really a great pick of squares
oh man
okay let's go here
wow
once again carving out a square for that
night
okay let's try to tame that knight
and let's start with this one
bishop c6
checaroni
uh king f2 is my first thought
let's go here though
that way after knight c3 now there isn't
a follow-up check
so what was my big plan with this
to play e4
if ever king f7 i have rook rook f6
okay
i should be able to play much faster now
oh man
it's a struggle
against this magnus guy
okay age 10 i think
we're getting them
finally
flush the king back he's running for the
hills
all right
um
let's save all the pawnees
let's push this guy
of course you hang up that pawn
okay
we'll get the other guy rolling
gonna give a check
now just have to watch out for
stalemates
get to the
still no stalematrix
right let's let's save safeguard my king
how about we do it like this
see that pass pawn push him
you dummy push him
keep going
getting flushed back
see how you like it
and
there we go
i think it's nearby
there
still no stalemate tricks magnus
there we got a main two
oh
struggle town
all right we got the trophy
i think this is where it might end
if i'm
being honest
uh magnus 10
no joke
that is for sure
okay magnus
11. 20
2001 this is where oh he started
training
with simon eggstein
okay he means business at 11.
let's go
all right let's try for
some
static structure
entering french defense land
um i'm gonna do something off beat
i'm prepared to under develop like this
it is not the best
objectively but
i'm gonna go for this
idea
to get rid of my bad guy
and
i may have already just kind of lost the
game
c4
where has all this underdeveloping
what is it
what would i gain from all this all
right let's let's go with this one
i'm in trouble
yeah queen there all right well this'll
be a quick game then
how about that
can i hold on
can i hold on
we're gonna find out
it's not gonna be easy okay well let's
let's transfer this knight into d5
oh i might be setting up d5 and then
bishop takes b6
okay hang on
should i play b5 here
b5
queen a5
what exactly have i
what have i accomplished there or no
what am i talking about
okay well now let's still go for this if
d5 whatever i can't really do too much
about that
all right at least that's a a bit of a
quiet move
how about
knight d5 straight away i guess so where
else is that guy going i need to create
a square for my bishop
also i need to be careful with d6 so
i think i need to take a timeout
to play
h6 all three miners could go there
let me go here
i'm not sure how i'm going to complete
development mind you
should i be playing
a5 here
with them the id of b5
my knight on b8
basically has to just stay put
let's see
if i play a5 and b4 i can't take but i
could play b5 queen b3 and then a4 i
don't really mind having my pawns fixed
on white
maybe i maybe i should go ahead and
flick in a5 instead of castles i think
eventually i will castle
but not just yet the queen is close to
trapped
maybe begin should i begin with b5
b5 and then a4
i'm gonna give this a go i guess it's uh
over emphasizing this uh
a
better bishop
scenario
that's all i have going for me right now
black has
better development
beautiful knight on e4 space on e5
and you know white also has a target
here i'm not quite sure it feels like
eventually i'm going to run out of ways
to improve my position so
these are
some of the
factors
running through my mind
um b5 or castles
i guess i'll give this one a go
shoo
the queen away
and before white could play a4 maybe i
go
go ahead with another pawn advance
let's try that now maybe i could somehow
weasel my knight around to c4 have a
good night on d5 it's my best piece far
and away
should i castle kingside even
hmm
it's kind of scary
get the bishop two knights that
intersection square on f6 for white
maybe some piece jump there
how do i complete development
all right how about
that knight d6 move could jump in it so
he could go there at some point do i
play rook a6
or how about uh yeah i mean i have to
defend
i think i want my knight on d7 so i'm
gonna have to move my queen
i have to i have to defend
c6
some king walk over to b7 maybe
i wonder about that that way too
far-fetched
d7
uh king
king d8 c8 b7 and then put the rook on
c8
i have to be careful though because of
the there's this queen takes b5 move i'm
probably asking for a sacrifice
or maybe i could begin with rook a6 lend
some more support to c6
or uh
i'm not sure how i want to do this maybe
rook a7 to b7 rook a7 to c7
and then walk my king
all right
it feels like i'm one move away and this
is gonna collapse on me all right
where's that night going
not sure but it is at least giving me a
moment to breathe maybe
that last move is an indication that
white is finding it difficult to
improve the position oh i should also
note that
i'm going i'm going to stop playing
not only
after a loss but a draw as soon as i
don't win a game
that's it i'm calling it quits
so
it's now the time where
i simply go for a walk
okay
let's go with this one
not the most natural
not the most natural
rook maneuver in the world
now
provoking weakness
here with beasts with g6 or
bishop to f8
do i under develop with my bishop or do
i play g6 is the question
there may soon be a target on h6
i guess we're gonna go for this
prepare to flee towards the king's side
is now that time
time to flee
yeah i'm gonna go for it
oh boy
and i think i need to do this so i could
finally cross over
to b7
oh man bishop a5
denied
oh no
now if king c8 there's bishop to a5
and then when my rook moves there's
queen takes b5
ouch
so now
i feel like
my king is simply cooked right in the
center
all right do i have to play
i have to play rook a7 to stop the
bishop
i may have to do that
okay
i don't think i could allow it to open
up won't go here
right there yeah just
working into all these
beautiful squares aren't you
all right
yeah i'm without a plan here
yeah i don't know what to do here
queen queen
i am so far off from getting a knight to
a c4
that's my only aim really here is to
somehow get this guy
on the c4 square
and even then there'd probably be a an
exchange sacrifice but i could at least
claim i'm up some material
okay
tough to find something here
that is for sure here's another maneuver
that's uh nearby for white knight h2 to
g4 and then
there's going to be some accident
happening on f
on f6 possibly
oh
okay how about this i guess we're gonna
make a queen move rook a6 knight d7 oh
release some pressure there did you
did you
okay well what about knight d7 now
did you just give me a moment to breathe
that's all i need
oh
hang on here
hang on mr magnus
because i might just go for king walk
well okay so let's let's maybe try for
this
um
let's try for this knight into c
c4
am i not getting that guy in there oh of
course this is where you stir up trouble
of course
well
i gotta chop that guy
oh boy
oh
boy
uh
dark square problems
yupper
knight on e5 so knight c4 rook takes
pawn takes 95 or maybe
95 straight away
all right
finish me off
i guess we're gonna go like this
oh you're taking with the pawn
hmm
i'd
what would i want to have happen here i
think i want to exchange queens but
it's anybody's guess how that
happens
yeah i don't know how that
ever comes about do i do i still need to
run
with my king
i think i need to try and run still over
here
oh okay now that's all right i think i
had to be prepared to go there anyhow
my rook is uh
my rook on h8
has a very useful
role here in stopping that queen from
entering on h7 if she ever gets there
forget about my a6 pawn
that guy would be toast
and then
the whites h-pawn would fly
okay
we don't want that happening
i also have to watch out for maybe some
battery
it's a good thing i have a knight that's
unchallengeable
huh how do i wheeze away
maybe even if i win this game i might be
done i'm exhausted
wearing me out
how can i position myself so that a
queen exchange is maybe
around the right around the corner
not really seeing that
maybe maybe i have to put my queen on h7
what do you think of that
all right let's begin
let's begin with this one
oh i forgot about that i was supposed to
play king b8 first
was it part of the plan it wasn't part
of the plan
oh i forgot okay it was probably dead no
matter what
okay and if i go here there's gonna be a
pawn push okay finish me off pawn push
maybe i move my king
okay maybe maybe now there's another
path to exchange queens
maybe that
maybe that kind of works out
sort of
oh boy oh boy
all right let's go here
okay you're setting up queen f6 or f3
aren't you
okay
and this is where you bring the pain
isn't it
yep
ah queen takes b5
brutal
i just ready to hang my rook rook b6
tough time man tough time
should we go for a queen exchange if i
go here
no let's find out queen f3
denied now i have to do ultra passive
stuff
babysit the pawn my king if i move my
king there's always some e7
stuff
yeah i'm totally
totally totally passive
do i want to be passive which one is
less
passive rook
rook f8 i guess
and less vulnerable yeah cutting out any
knight f4
i see what you're up to and there's not
much i could do about it
that's just how it is
it's already out for a queen exchange
maybe at some point i could play f6
i don't know
maybe get the queens off that point
oh okay queen there
defending the rook queen h7 maybe
my knight doesn't have a square
the only square is b6 but
yeah all right i gotta stop that queen
h7 move
all right i guess we just wait and see
how you make progress
bend off the one moved fret
you're ready to eliminate the knight
all right i guess we go here
gonna stop that
okay
it feels like that might be some sign
that
white isn't making progress but
i don't know can i get a rook off
that rook on a6 is a big dummy
i don't know where am i supposed to go
with the what am i supposed to do
uh i guess we go here
and then here this is wonderful
technique right here
okay now the rook is attacked
all right this is what's this is what my
position is down to oh
oh oh
very nice very nice okay that's that's a
good way to end it
so smooth earlier if that was tried i
could recapture and i'd be on the queen
on e4
but now
if i take with the c pawn there's rook
c7 if i take with the e pawn there's
going to be d6
okay that was a nice finish here i don't
think we have to go any further
a sudden end
could have been held if i didn't give up
that b-pawn i don't know
i am i'm pretty sure i'm down for the
count here let me just double check
[Music]
i think i'm gonzo
god take the rook
let's play out a couple more moves
and my rook was hanging there
yeah i think
go just a little bit more
i don't i'm not playing on just because
i i think i could win
but
just to make it look crystal clear
okay that bishop's ready to play to c5
probably a lot of other stuff too
yeah look at that
and this guy here remains a big dummy
for the remainder of the game so my plan
there to try and blockade was not a good
one
i felt the pressure right away with c4
is a very nice way to crack open the
position which makes a whole lot of
sense
since i played some
developing moves and then under
developing but that strategy clearly did
not work against magnus age 11
down
for the count i go
i resign
okay anyhow this was just a bit of a fun
video that's as good as i could do
magnus 11
tough player
okay as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below i hope you enjoyed it
and yeah maybe found it a little bit fun
that's all for now take care bye
you